grimes is opening up about her son with
tesla billionaire elon musk and reveals
they're on a first name basis
oh yeah in a new vogue video documenting
the singer's prep for the met gala she
discussed how their son whom they call x
has changed her life
i think having a baby was a big kind of
like rebirth for me i like artistically
like it just like i don't know being a
mother feels weird to say for some
reason i don't like identify with that
word which is also really weird because
ex he says claire but he doesn't say
like mama which is so i'm like how are
you
like maybe he can like sense my
distaste for the word mother which i
don't even know i have a distaste for it
because i like respect with i just i
don't i can't identify with it
[Music]
okay okay okay okay i know it's the met
gala so we can't do like a deep eye but
if i was behind the lens doing this
whole documentary of her getting ready i
would have been like let's dive deeper
into that so you don't identify with the
word mom let's go further obviously you
know her and
elon i mean both of them
they think very freely they think very
advanced you know obviously we've seen
kind of what you've seen what elon has
accomplished so we can imagine that
they're going to redefine a lot of
things that are you know societal norms
but
to not identify with the word mom your
kid is so young not even
calling you mom it's really interesting
and you know there's been discussion a
lot of discussion especially in schools
and what not regarding the word mom dad
you know why we call our parents these
names why don't we call them by our
first names and really when it comes
down to it
a newborn baby it's easier for them to
say ma pa da
you know it's easy for babies to
identify like your little baby who can
barely speak english or just speak in
general ain't gonna be like keisha
and then can't say anything else like
there's no way my baby's gonna say he
should before mama or dada that's just
not a thing and obviously
all over the world mom and dad is
identified doesn't matter what language
you speak we know who mom is and who dad
is we know what that means so it's just
i find it very fascinating when kids
call their parents by their first name i
know that that wouldn't go over well in
my house okay
mama
daddy to this day i'm a grown woman and
i'm scared i'm shook at honey i will
never call my mama by her first name
it's the audacity for me
being being in a filipino household
there are more than one first name that
i could call my mom
like yeah she has her name and then she
has a name that she's gone by her whole
life and other whatever other nicknames
her friends have given her mom was just
easier i'm curious about like um
did
x start making those you know
sounds
no you're not going to call me i'm just
about how that went down so that he is
now making the decision to call her by
her first name is that his decision
i don't know at any rate interesting
but i think it is fascinating and i do
love the idea of doing that deep dive
into
um
not identifying and connecting with the
word mother is it the word or the
concept or how she perceives the concept
or
i guess there's a lot to go to go into
there
yeah there's definitely a deep dive
there and i think when you're a child
and your name is ex
like his name is so long and complicated
and not long it's not long and it's not
complicated but it's different it's very
unique so i think that when you're a
child with a very unique name and i'm
sure there's been multiple discussions
around your name you're probably
thinking about
other people's names and what you do who
knows i feel like this kid is just gonna
blow my mind like
it's interesting this is this is a this
deserves a deep dive and a further
interview
someone
interview her let's you know come to e2
canada wherever you're going to go but
someone needs to talk to her about this
this is very it's an interesting topic
what's everybody here saying we got zoe
yeah saying she's a mom she doesn't
identify with it make it make sense
um yes
nicole says they are weird and i think
that they are happy with people saying
that they're not like quote-unquote
normal they like to be unusual by other
people's standards
for sure
yeah i like what carla said she said i
like her vibe of just being uniquely her
i do really like that
[Music]
hmm bart says she didn't give a lot of
details on why a lot to unpack yes bart
there's a lot to impact this is low-key
stressing me out i'm not gonna lie
that's a story
with regards to her zoe says does grimes
identify as non-binary i never really
thought about that
oh my gosh that's something totally to
consider you know maybe not that
specific
yeah but just the idea that mom is
considered female and then dad is male
but what if
wow i never even i love the idea of
opening my mind up to something that yes
i like that i like that's a really good
question
since the comments for me guys it's the
comments for me
we're gonna explore this further all
right guys who needs the interview
everyone's gonna go into it in the
comments that's good
yeah but it's really a it's an
interesting discussion because it can
move the needle further on what is
normal and i love those types of
discussions